mathematicians have used symbolic
notations since the subject first began
you see them on Babylonian tablets to
mind Pappas on the pages of Libra bachi
the manuscript that brought modern
arithmetic to Western Europe in the 13th
century and in modern math textbooks
like the one shown written by me in 2012
yet most of the mathematics we perform
every day usually referred to us
everyday math takes place mostly in our
minds everyday math is primarily a way
of thinking so where do the symbols come
in this scene from the 1997 hit movie
Good Will Hunting starring Matt Damon
and Robin Williams shows a mathematician
doing math but where is that doing
actually taking place in will hunting's
mind on the board obviously a mixture of
both more generally is math something
you see on a page or something you do in
your head well let me ask a seemingly
different question is this music always
music what you find in the action on the
right
in this case we have no doubt our ears
provide the answer
music is what the penis creates in the
audience ears on the right you have
music and activity on the left a static
score an activity and a representation
now let's go back to my previous
question where's the math the answer is
the same what you see on a page is a
representation of mathematics the math
itself takes place inside the head to
make the distinction clear I generally
use the term mathematical thinking to
refer to the mental act of doing math
and use the word mathematics in a looser
more generic way from that perspective
those symbols on a page our user
interface to mathematics I want you to
keep in mind this distinction between
mathematical thinking which takes place
in your head and mathematical
representations which you see on pages
in a book it's at the heart of
everything I'm going to show you that
symbolic representation is extremely
powerful for doing mathematics which is
what it was developed for but it sucks
big time for beginners learning math it
provides a barrier to learning what I
would fear too is the symbol barrier
that's my term but introduced it only
after I read the first of what when many
studies showing just how much of a
barrier to learning it is in that first
study carried out in the early 1990s in
Street markets in Brazil research has
posed to shoppers as the observed and
recorded school children looking after
their parents market stalls they found
that the children had developed
sophisticated and efficient mental
strategies for handling cash sales and
did so with an effectively perfect
accuracy rate of 98% yet when the
researchers subsequently gave the
children a paper and pencil test with
the very same width
took problems that the researchers had
presented to them at the market stall
their accuracy rate dropped to 37
percent the mathematics was the same the
problem was a symbolic representation it
wasn't a math issue it was an ingress
Taquan the interface that was developed
to do math is a poor one for a beginner
learning math so why do we use symbols
to teach math it turns out that using
symbols to teach math is a consequence
of a powerful technology that became
available in the 15th century the
printing press prior to the printing
press mathematics texts were it mostly
in words with the only symbols being
numerals the reason why mathematicians
before the printing press will up their
books in prose was a hand written books
were duplicated by scribes often monks
in monasteries most of whom were not
familiar with mathematics and therefore
could not be relied on to accurately
reproduce symbolic expressions but with
the printing press that problem went
away mathematicians were one of the
first groups to send manuscripts to
printers and ever since mathematics has
been taught using books with symbolic
expressions here's an example from the
very first algebra textbook written by
the Persian mathematician al-khwarizmi
in 9th century Baghdad if you were a
math student back then this is the kind
of problem you'd be asked to solve and
the way you would write the answer do
you have any idea what kind of a problem
it is let me show you how the same
problem was written and solved after the
printing press allowed books to use
symbols it's a simple quadratic equation
though you need to master the symbolic
language of algebra to do it this way
once you do the process becomes much
simpler
is simply much easier to do using
symbols the symbols were banished purely
in order to write textbooks that could
be accurately duplicated by hand
the printing press changed all that
but that technologically-driven change
in representation came at a price for
learners the symbol barrier well today
we have a new technology the digital
tablets or even a regular computer
screen is paper on steroids are there
alternative ways we can represent
mathematics using this new technology
that allow us to break the symbol
barrier and remove a known obstacle to
learning take a look at this problem it
looks hard but is it hard because of the
thinking required to understand it and
solve it what does the difficulty lie in
a symbolic representation well here's
the same problem represented differently
on a tablet it's an app I developed and
I'll talk about it in a minute in both
cases the problem comes in three parts
the first part asks you to solve
something the other two parts ask you to
solve it more efficiently you'll see
some other commonalities as well the
fall and the 7 for instance but whereas
we usually think of the problem on the
right as college level algebra the one
on the left has been solved by hundreds
of thousands of kids as young as 8 all
over the world and when they solve it
they perform the same steps as you would
use if you did it using the symbolic
algebra on the right the only difference
is the representation the representation
on the left is just more efficient for
representing and solving this kind of
problem this is the printing press
revolution all over again a new
technology has provided us with ways to
represent mathematics that's a more
effective for beginners learning math
the earlier technology made math
learning symbolic at the cost of the
symbol barrier today's new
technology enables us to bring a simple
barrier I'll come back to where that
leaves symbols in a minute they are not
going to go away
but first let me respond to one remark
you are probably bursting to make isn't
that alternative representation just a
child's game a toy yes it is so too is
this at least that's how we view it
today but the abacus is one of
humankind's most powerful inventions it
democratized arithmetic making it
possible for ordinary people all over
the world to handle numbers in trade and
commerce and government as a result what
we now see as a toy quite literally
changed the world in theory we all know
how to use an abacus to a few of us
today are skilled at it let me show you
how to use my app to solve systems of
linear equations or perhaps I should say
linear relationships in up to four
unknowns you operate the device this one
has two unknowns by rotating any of the
small cogs a certain number of times to
turn the large wheel the number of cogs
the wheel turns depends on the number of
teeth on the small cog the goal is to
collect the keys and the other items on
the wheel by bringing them under the
zero marker at the top of the wheel
let's see some young kids use this
device okay here we go
starts the game will - it's a small cog
to turn the big wheel tries to collect
the keys and the objects on this
particular puzzle you can rotate each
small cog up to five times
collected the key solve the puzzle got a
trophy now let's watch this young girl
being helped by her father
where she collects the third key solves
the puzzle and gets congratulated by her
dad wonderful
just as the abacus change the way people
did math so two apps like these can
change the way people learn maths well
perhaps not the abacus anymore it
operates a to lower level for today's
world
these are all apps that provide
alternative representations of
mathematics making use of the dynamic
interactive properties of the tablet or
the computer screen to break the symbol
barrier in fact at present these are
almost the only math learning apps
designed to provide alternative
representations of mathematics the other
25,000 or so math learning apps
available on the App Store alone all
rely on the traditional symbolic
representation which is a bit like
producing printed math textbooks in the
15th century that were all prose which
didn't happen but isn't it important for
kids to master the symbols you might ask
well for kids who are not going into
stem or perhaps the financial world it's
much more important that they master
basic everyday mathematical thinking and
apps like these have been shown to
develop that ability and to do so much
more quickly as a result of bypassing
the symbol barrier but that aside it
simply makes sense to separate the two
processes of learning how to think
mathematically and mastering the
symbolic representation once a child has
learned how to solve linear equations
maybe I should call them linear
relationships using my app they can then
learn the symbolic way to do it in fact
we can provide them with a version of
our app that helps them make that
transition with this app when you solve
the puzzle using the gear mechanism on
the right the symbolic equation solution
is displayed on the left alternatively
you can enter the symbolic equations on
the left and the key is on the right
move to solve the problem let me show
you one other app that breaks a simple
barrier and then helps the players make
the transition to the symbolic
representation after they've mastered
the mathematical thinking
it's called dragonbox and it focuses on
solving linear equations if one unknown
it comes from a small start-up in Norway
the two
out of the equation are shown as two
halves of a rectangle like the two sides
of a tennis court the unknown is a box
surrounded by a sparkling halo the goal
is to isolate the Box on one side of the
court
with everything else on the other side
that releases a small dragon and solving
further problems feeds the dragon so it
grows bigger the player manipulates the
various items according to rules that
are analogues of the ancient rules for
solving equations going back to our
charisma with the stipulation that
whatever you do to one side you have to
do to the other
here goes at first the objects the kids
manipulate a typical looking game
objects no mathematical symbols negation
is turning over which swaps colors
then the picture of objects are
gradually replaced by algebraic symbols
but the player's actions remain the same
and there's an equal sign across the
central divide
then finally the tennis court background
disappears and it looks like traditional
algebra on paper though the player is
still moving objects the same way
and she sold it well done there's
research to back up this alternative
representation approach a major study of
many thousands of kids run by the
University of Washington in Seattle in
Washington State Minnesota and Norway in
2013-14 showed that kids mastered the
solution of linear equations in one
unknown in an hour and a half in a game
context studies at the end they've
mastered the algebraic thinking and they
are familiar with the symbols but some
work is still required to become fluent
in the symbolic language that study
wasn't set up to evaluate the learning
efficacy of dragonbox so the results
weren't published as a scientific paper
but the size of the study population
gave the measured outcomes considerable
weight my old game was it trouble was
subjected to a rigorous scientific study
by researchers at Stanford I wasn't
involved by the way due to conflict of
interest considerations the Stanford
team found evidence of significant
improvements in number sense and overall
problem-solving after just two hours of
play spread over the months relative to
a comparison group the results were
published in leading peer-reviewed
journal in 2015 that big improvement
after just a hundred and twenty minutes
play was so surprising that I contacted
a colleague in Finland working on game
based learning and asked him if he would
conduct a similar study of the app he
did so with a twist instead of just
using a written pre and post tests to
measure improvements he also used a
fractions learning game he developed
called semi Deus as an additional pre
and post-test the results were almost
identical to those from the Stanford
study the finish results were published
in the same journal as the Stanford
study so there's good reason to believe
we've seen the future of beginning math
education
where we are finally able to separate
out the task of learning the
mathematical thinking that goes on in
our minds from mastery of the symbolic
language that goes on the page we can at
last break the simple barrier that
prevents good learning
and if you want to find out more here's
a book I wrote on the subject and links
to my various coordinates thank you for
watching